tout ce qu'on peut dire à propos d'un
intervalle de confiance et qu'un
paramètre métaphysique soit si trouver
soi ne pas s'y trouver
cette citation et du statisticien
williams brics et sachant que les
intervalles de confiance sont l'un des
piliers des sciences modernes
à côté des fameuses paix value dont on a
déjà beaucoup parlé ça peut paraître
être un constat très sévère aujourd'hui
on va essayer de clarifier les propos de
brigue et voir en quoi comme la paix
value les intervalles de confiance ont
quand même hyper utile si les sciences
ont énormément gagné en crédibilité au
20e siècle
c'est en très grande partie grâce à ces
intervalles de confiance et je trouve ça
malencontreux qu'on les célèbres pas
autant que disons la mécanique
newtonienne ceci étant dit comme la paix
value les intervalles de confiance sont
aussi souvent mal compris y compris par
les scientifiques voir les statisticiens
en tout cas moi quand je suis devenu
docteur en mathématiques appliquées
j'avais une compréhension extrêmement
bancal de ces intervalles de confiance
en particulier ces intervalles ne sont
pas vraiment ce qu'on pourrait croire
ils peuvent être extrêmement trompeurs
mais avant d'en venir là arrêtons-nous
sur l'intérêt de raisonner avec des
intervalles trop souvent on a tendance à
s'arrêter à des chiffres précis par
exemple pour estimer le coût de sauver
une vie on a envie de s'arrêter à un
chiffre exact
typiquement en 2015 business insider
annonça que si on s'y prenait bien ce
coup était égal à 3337 dollars et 6
centimes et comment dire je ne connais
pas bien l'étude
mais je suis à peu près sûr que ce coût
n'est pas exactement 3337 dollars et 6
centimes
ne serait-ce que pour des histoires de
fluctuations monétaires ou d'inflation
mais au delà d'une erreur potentiel le
problème avec des chiffres précis c'est
qu'ils ne reflètent pas l'étendue de
notre ignorance à quel point est-ce que
business insider était sûr de lui-même
est-ce qu'il était sûr à un dollar près
ou est ce plutôt l'ordre de grandeur qui
paraît plutôt valide à savoir quelques
milliers de dollars
idéalement bien sûr si on est bayésiens
plutôt que de déclarer un nombre précis
il faudrait décrire toute notre
incertitudes typiquement avec une courbe
de la distribution du coût minimal
probable pour sauver une vie par exemple
avec la courbe à l'écran qui dit que ce
goût elle est possiblement de quelques
centaines de dollars
mais il est probablement de quelques
milliers de dollars et il est très
probablement en dessous de 10 mille
dollars
sauf que calculée et communiquer tout
une courbe comme ça ce n'est vraiment
pas pratique
l'idée des intervalles et de concevoir
un langage intermédiaire entre l'excès
de confiance d'un nombre précis et la
complexité d'une distribution
probabiliste et c'est d'ailleurs un tel
langage que guy roux à la docte
désormais divo elle estime ainsi que le
coût de sauver une vie est entre 900 et
7000 $ il est dans l'intervalle 907
milles dollars
alors soit dit au passage j'avoue ne pas
avoir pris le temps de lire les détails
du calcul de cet intervalle mais si vous
êtes curieux je vous invite vivement à
lire le blog de guy noël qui est
extrêmement transparent à ce sujet
aujourd'hui la question qui m'intéresse
c'est plus le degré de validité de cet
intervalle en particulier qu'elle est
l'interprétation philosophique de cet
intervalle peut-on faire confiance à ce
genre d'intervalle pour bien répondre à
ces questions il est important de
distinguer trois sortes d'intervalle
différents à savoir les intervalles de
fluctuation les intervalles de confiance
et intervalle de crédence dans tous ces
cas on va donner des intervalles comme
907 milles dollars
et il est si tentant de penser qu'ils
parlent de la même chose
tout comme il est si tentant de
confondre la vraisemblance des données
et la crédence des théories cependant
une telle confusion risque de conduire à
des contresens
donc même si ça va forcément vous faire
quelques noeuds au cerveau
je vous le promets ça vaut le coup de
bien démêler tout ça
bon en fait aujourd'hui on aura le temps
de parler que des intervalles de
fluctuation et de confiance
on abordera les intervalles de crédence
la prochaine fois commençons par les
intervalles de fluctuation en gros ils
reviennent à dire que si je refais une
même expérience plusieurs fois je dois
m'attendre à des fluctuations dans les
données d'une expérience à l'autre
l'intervalle de fluctuation est donc un
intervalle de fluctuation des données un
autre point important est que
l'intervalle de fluctuation concerne ce
qu'on s'attend à obtenir autrement dit
il s'agit d'une prédiction sur les
données et qui dit prédictions dix
prédictions selon une certaine théorie
tu es un intervalle de fluctuation isf
dépend donc de la théorie thé qu'on
considère pour mettre en valeur cette
dépendance
on peut la notte isf de thé comme tous
les autres intervalles à venir
l'intervalle de fluctuation dépend
également d'un niveau de probabilité
par exemple on peut considérer un
intervalle de fluctuation à 95%
intervalle de fluctuation isf de thé 95%
pour une autorité et un niveau de
vraisemblance 95% doit alors être tels
que si la théorie t est vrai alors la
probabilité que les données se trouvent
dans l'intervalle de fluctuation irf de
thé et 95% est égal à 95%
autrement dit on doit avoir l'équation
la probabilité lorsque je tire des eaux
hasard que des appartiennent à
l'intervalle de fluctuation t 95 %
sachant que la théorie t est vrai est
égal à 95%
telle est la propriété fondamentale de
l'intervalle de fluctuation elle dit ce
que l'on peut attendre des données avec
grande probabilité si on suppose la
théorie tes vrais bien souvent en
pratique dépend de paramètres souvent
noté avec diverses lettres grecques
comme mussig marulanda fonds utilise la
lettre p tout ceci appartient alors au
monde des théories ce que je rends ici
explicite en utilisant la couleur jaune
verte
par opposition à la couleur bleue qui
correspond aux données l'intervalle de
fluctuation valeurs typiquement
ressembler à quelque chose comme
intervalle de fluctuation de paramètres
paix sigma est à 95% est égal à
l'intervalle paie moins en verve 96,6
mode / à sin cara de haine et puissant
1,96 et cinéma / async à rennes même si
ça dépend bien sûr du niveau de frais
sans nuances comme considère et surtout
de la théorie thé avec laquelle on
effectue les prédictions de façon
cruciale ces intervalles de fluctuation
ne doivent pas être confondus avec les
intervalles de confiance qui eux
concerne les valeurs des paramètres de
la théorie en fait un intervalle de
confiance n'a de sens que pour des
paramètres de la théorie et ça ça veut
dire en particulier que si une théorie
n'a aucun paramètre alors la notion d'
intervalle de confiance n'a aucun sens
c'est d'ailleurs pour cette raison que
william briggs parle de paramètres
métaphysique les paramètres de la
théorie sont fabriqués par la théorie et
ne s'agit en aucun cas de données
observable en particulier si on
considère que tous les modèles sont faux
on en vient vite à la conclusion les
intervalles de confiance ne nous disent
rien de ce qui est
il ne parle que de ce qu'on s'imagine
sur ce qui est y compris quand on sait
pertinemment que ce qu'on imagine est
faux alors je vais quand même tempérer
ce que je dis puisque mieux ajuster la
crédibilité de nos modèles permet en
fait de modifier ce qu'on s'attend de ce
qui est donc même si les intervalles de
confiance concerne des paramètres
métaphysique
ils aident néanmoins à mieux décrire et
prédire le monde tous les intervalles de
confiance sont faux et certains sont
utiles en particulier l'incertitude sur
les paramètres permet ensuite de déduire
une incertitude adéquate à avoir sur les
données prédite par nos modèles il est
donc extrêmement utile de mesurer notre
incertitudes sur nos modèles typiquement
à l'aide d'un intervalle de confiance
sur les paramètres du modèle plus
formellement l'intervalle de confiance
sur un paramètre ap le et a créé suppose
qu'on considère un ensemble de théories
t2t et à paramétrer arteta l'intervalle
de confiance sur teta s'appuie ensuite
sur les données pour essayer de
localiser d'état par exemple considérons
la théorie dite et de paix qui prédit
que les données sont indépendantes est
identiquement distribués et prennent la
valeur 1 avec probabilité est dans le
jargon on parle d'une suite de variables
indépendantes de bernouilli dès lors
sachant des données associées à une
fréquence empirique f de la valeur 1 on
pourra concevoir un intervalle de
confiance à 95 % pour la valeur du
paramètre métaphysique paix qui sera de
la forme f -1 96 s / racine carrée de
nfp 1,96
s / racine carrée de haine ou fps sont
des variables qui sont calculés à partir
des données observées par les équations
que je donne ici les détails des calculs
importe peu ce qui est important à voir
c'est que l'intervalle de confiance est
calculé à partir des données des alors
on pourrait croire que du coup le
paramètre paix à une probabilité de 95 %
de se trouver dans l'intervalle de
confiance à 95 % cités plus haut on a
tendance à penser que l'intervalle de
confiance décrit notre incertitudes sur
la valeur des paramètres
en fait non il s'agit là d'une erreur
aussi grave que de penser que la paix va
lui est étonné est la crédence de la
théorie non je le répète la probabilité
que l'intervalle de confiance à 95 %
contiennent la vraie valeur de paix
n'est pas de 95%
d'abord parce qu'il n'est pas clair
qu'il ya une vraie valeur de paix
rappelez-vous paix est une quantité
métaphysique
tous les modèles sont faux en
particulier il est tout à fait possible
de calculer des intervalles de confiance
de paramètres de modèle complètement
faux mais surtout l'intervalle de
confiance se déduit uniquement des
données par construction il omet donc
les préjugés
les yeux or selon un proverbe bayésiens
sans préjugés aucune conclusion ne peut
être tirée
dès lors un intervalle de confiance ne
peut pas être ce qu'un bail vient est
amené à croire je vous renvoie vers des
épisodes précédents où on a parlé de
l'importance des préjugés ou vers le
prochain épisode où on parlera des
intervalles de crédence qui prennent bel
et bien en compte ces préjugés pour
l'heure j'aimerais insister sur la
propriété fondamentale des intervalles
de confiance celle qui pourrait sembler
justifié la terminologie intervalle de
confiance à 95 %
cette propriété garanti la fréquence de
validité d'un intervalle de confiance si
l'on suppose que notre théorie
paramétrer est vrai pour une valeur du
paramètre et si on répète la collecte de
données
autrement dit en langage probabiliste la
propriété fondamentale des intervalles
de confiance est le fait que la
probabilité lorsque je tire la donne
était au hasard que le vrai paramètres
état se trouve à l'intérieur de
l'intervalle de confiance construit à
partir de la donner des et avec un
niveau de vraisemblance égal à 95%
sachant que la théorie t2t tas est vrai
cette probabilité sur la donne et des
est égal à 95% ou dit autrement si on
considère sans théorie paramétrer vrai
pour une valeur des paramètres si on
collecte des données pour chacune de ces
théories et si on calcule des
intervalles de confiance à chaque fois
alors environ 95% de ces intervalles
contiendront la vraie valeur des
paramètres
voici une interprétation adéquate des
intervalles de confiance ou presque il
ya quelques trucs bizarres a rajouté la
première chose c'est qu'on pourra tout
simplement construire l'intervalle de
confiance qui ne contient que la valeur
de teta ou avoir un intervalle valide à
100% mais le jeu proposé par jardine et
man le créateur des intervalles de
confiance c'est de chercher à construire
des intervalles qui sont valides
quelle que soit la valeur de têtards
sauf qu'il est en général impossible
d'avoir une fonction qui as des as aussi
l'intervalle de confiance qui dépendent
des est de 95% tels que pour toutes et à
la probabilité lorsque je tire des eaux
hasard que tu étais appartiennent à
intervalles de confiance sachant que la
théorie de tes deux états est vrai il
est improbable que cette volonté soit
exactement égal à 95% pour toutes les
valeurs de l'état en fait le jeu proposé
par zinman est plutôt de garantir que
notre construction des intervalles de
confiance est telle que pour toute
valeur de l'état
la probabilité que l'état soit à
l'intérieur de l'intervalle de confiance
construit à partir des données des
sachants la théorie t d est un vrai est
au moins égal à 95% et peut-être
également pas trop supérieur à 95%
bref mathématiquement tout ça en fait
c'est pas si jolie que ça et c'est
surtout pas si bien définis en
particulier ne semble pas y avoir de
solution canonique qui fonctionnerait
pour toute théorie t2t tas mais ce n'est
pas le plus problématique
le plus gros problème c'est qu'une telle
interprétation semble très fréquentes
east même si elle offre une garantie
rassurante sur un intervalle de
confiance dans leur ensemble
n'ignorant bien sûr tous les problèmes
de biais de publications elle ne nous
dit en fait pas grand-chose sur un cas
précis en particulier pour un bail vient
en tout cas il ne faut absolument pas
confondre la probabilité lorsque je tire
des eaux hasard que l'état appartiennent
à l'intervalle de confiance
construit à partir de d1 niveau 95 %
sachant la théorie t2t ta vraie avec une
probabilité qui est sont de plus
pertinente pour le balisier à savoir la
probabilité lorsque je tire t t au
hasard que tu états appartiennent
effectivement à l'intervalle de
confiance se construit à partir de dea
niveau de 95 % sachant les données des
c2 probabilités sont très différentes
la première correspond davantage à une
sorte de vraisemblance puisqu'elle
correspond à une probabilité des données
alors que la seconde ressemble beaucoup
plus à une sorte de crédence puisqu'elle
correspond à la probabilité de théories
en particulier en général non la
crédence qu'un paramètre se trouve dans
un intervalle de confiance à 95 % n'est
pas 95% et pour le vérifier je vous
invite à calculer les intervalles de
confiance de la méta analyse des
expériences de prémonition dont on a
parlé dans l'épisode 12 l'intervalle de
confiance que vous aurez calcul est
décrite il vraiment ce qu'il nous faut
conclure de l'expérience probablement
pas bref
ces vidéos sont assez techniques et
difficiles à comprendre notamment car on
a tendance à confondre des notions
similaires comme les intervalles de
fluctuation de confiance et de crédence
tout comme on confond si souvent la
vraisemblance des données et la crédence
des théories mais j'espère que vous
commencez à mieux discerner ses concepts
différents ou du moins à sentir qu'il ya
là de nombreuses subtilités importante
que vous avez peut-être omise
si vous en êtes arrivés à cette
conclusion c'est qu'on a en fait fait un
énorme pas aujourd'hui la 1ère fois on a
parlé de l'importance de faire des
erreurs de sortir de sa zone de confort
et du coup de publier des trucs sous
incertitudes et du cookie ou de
probabilités parfois pas si négligeable
d'avoir des erreurs et coucou yul nous
fait remarquer qu'en fait les réflexions
qu'on a eu la d re fois qui s'applique
vraiment plus aux sciences en fait
s'applique également aux mathématiques
et d'ailleurs à ce propos depuis
quelques mois lorsque je fais des
mathématiques notre honda recherche en
mathématiques j'en fais encore un tout
petit peu lorsque j'énonce des
conjectures que j'aimerais prouver
j'associe assez rapidement à ces
conjectures des niveaux de crédence non
seulement la vérité de du théorème que
je cherche à prouver et en ma capacité à
prouver le théorème en question et
j'essaie de jouer avec ces probabilités
lorsque cette probabilité est supérieur
à 50% moi je vais essayer de démontrer
la conjecture en question et quand je
n'arrive pas à la démonter ou que j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya quelque chose qui
bug
ben je crois cette probabilité on la
vérité du théorème et quand cette
probabilité est suffisamment faible je
me mets à chercher des contre exemples
et ça je pense que c'est un réflexe très
intéressant à voir en mathématiques de
façon générale essayer de prouver ce
qu'ils nous pensons que probable mais
lorsque l'on bute essayer de retourner
le problème est de se demander
finalement si ce qu'on pensait ne serait
pas en fait faux et en fait comme on en
reparlera en fait pour les mathématiques
le belize à nice mme pure est un fait
assez inutile puisque la pure bayésienne
c'est automatiquement qu'elle théorème
sont vrais ou faux plus
cependant en pratique on a des
puissances de calcul limitée du coup il
nous faut faire du belize à nice mme
pragmatique et se bat izan isme
pragmatique et semble extrêmement utile
en mathématiques aussi à bassiste lui
fait la remarque que la vidéo de veritas
yonne en fait un champ d'application qui
va au-delà du simple petit exemple ou de
la curiosité scientifique qui est
suggéré par la vidéo est carrément et
d'ailleurs je vous suggère vivement
d'essayer d'avoir une analyse bayésienne
du problème de veritas yonne qu'est-ce
qu'il aurait été le plus optimal de
faire si on jouait au jeu de veritas y
sommes pourquoi est-ce qu'on est amené
par exemple à vouloir penser que c'est
une suite de puissance de 2 et 1 ci
dessus
quelles sont les alternatives qui sont
le plus probable pourquoi ces
alternatives semble plus probable
qu'elle ait finalement votre préjugés
sur la règle que veritas yom a en tête
voilà je pense que c'est les réflexions
qui sont assez fascinante on a déjà
parlé de réflexion similaire avec
thibaut enterrement dans un épisode de
taxes y sommes toujours content d'aller
voir si ça vous intéresse
et c'est aussi très intéressant de faire
le lien entre ces problèmes très
théoriques et des problèmes beaucoup
plus concret de faire cette
transférabilité qui me semble très
importante à faire entre des problèmes
assez abstrait avec elle on n'a pas
d'eau liga nice mais c'est assez facile
de poser le raisonnement vers des
problèmes malheureusement on a beaucoup
plus de mal à garder notre calme et
appliqué les principes de la rationalité
l étape que j'avais mais cet épisode la
prochaine fois on va continuer à parler
d'intervalle devant moi je suis
encouragée à vraiment et c'est beaucoup
plus d intervalle que des chiffres pour
raisonner mais en particulier on parlera
des intervalles de crédence qui eux ou
un bref mouvement parisien
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la pente à la partager
pense à vous abonner pour une tente et
futurs épisodes
merci au type air power dont et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois
c'est déjà un truc qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que l'intervalle de
fluctuation l'utilisent lorsqu'on
connaît la proportion p alors soit on la
connaît soit on est capable d'en faire
l'hypothèse en tout cas on peut écrire
au départ de l'exercice mme p égal temps
alors que l'intervalle de confiance lui
sert justement à estimer cette
proportion théorique donc au départ de
l'exercice je ne connais pas paix et je
veux justement est bien en obtenir une
valeur approché qu'on va obtenir dans ce
fameux intervalle de confiance